what is your net worth we have right at
2.2 million my name is David this is my
wife Leah and we lived in a small little
community outside of Houston okay Leah's
very outgoing energy and I'm the steady
dull guy yeah
for David and Leah life is just as much
about the journey as it is the
destination they make the most of the
present even as they look toward the
future the couple both contribute to
their lifestyles indistinct waves while
Leah finds clever ways to save and is
more of the free spirit
David is a man that can get things done
well when Lee and I first got married no
you have these dreams of wealth family
where I have so many children and
running this house we don't do this
wrong with that and a lot of those plans
took different directions and the timing
may not have been right but you know of
all those plans none of them had to do
with being a millionaire
I just wanted to experience the next day
or week I mean I can speak I think for
both of us that we didn't grow up with a
whole lot and I had a car debt and I had
furniture debt College oh yeah I was
still paying on one little bit of a
college loan and and when we got married
all he had was a car and a bet we spent
the first few years you know maybe I
don't know first two three years paying
off my debt and so thanks and then we
just were a living life we didn't have a
plan I guess you know in our culture and
our culture is really not friendly
towards people who are really trying to
make a plan for their money and
everything about our culture says this
is what success is this is what you need
to look like you need to look like
you're rich
and I will say that there was a time
when I felt just pressure from our
culture to be something that I'm totally
not because it's easier for people that
are making tons of money but if you're
on normal income you really have to walk
against the flow of culture and that's
tough that means you got to be weird as
dave says yes a little bit about how you
got introduced today yeah we met in our
church Oh to Dave Ramsey not this day
you know how I get introduced today
Ramsey has a radio show I started
lifting years ago and I listen pretty
much every day and Dane says things that
we we adhere to well I like that one
thing where he says you know people
spend money to impress people that they
don't even like honestly I spent so much
time at negative emotions looking at
other people oh don't spend any time
with negative emotion get a goal go for
that put that emotion into a goal when I
got a goal I lost all those negative
emotions and that I gotta say that was
one of the best things that that
happened through this whole process our
fast-paced culture can be challenging
sure but setting goals gives us the
advantage we can see clearly where it is
we're going and through a series of
small victories Leah and David were able
to become millionaires
instead of spending money he was out in
the front yard playing football baseball
wiffle ball with their kids I know that
there's a lot of people out there living
a lifestyle that they cannot afford in
that stress and it ruins marriages it
grows families not worth it three
discipline comes freedom and today is a
good day to start making small victories
because it has been a series of small
victories and a lot of setbacks too you
know but you can't get discouraged by
those things my encouragement would be
to set your financial goals because if
you can stay focused on that goal that's
one goal that gets you closer to the
future it's not about money it's about
character and denying yourself those
things somehow build some character you
know if we can start pretty much almost
at the midpoint of our marriage there's
hope for everybody taking every moment
captive for David and Leah hasn't hurt
their future because their lifestyle was
in place but when the time comes they're
ready to retire and stay as inspired as
they've been since the beginning
you
[Music]
you